hi in this video I will talk about
synaptic plasticity here is our brain
taking the information from the sensory
environment processing that information
and the output is behavior
now our sensory environment is not
constant it is changing day by day this
fluctuating and in order to make our
behavior consistent our brain need to be
flexible there should be some degree of
flexibility in our nervous system since
that we can adapt to the ever-changing
environment and that degree of
flexibility is known as plasticity at
our nervous system plasticity could
occur at different levels starting from
behavioral level to circuit level to
cellular and molecular level today I
would talk about cellular level of
plasticity and plasticity in the
junction between the two neurons that
mean in synapses you might think that
plastic changes at the neuronal level
could only occur at synapses but this
notion is not true because other levels
like membrane conductances the intrinsic
excitable properties of the neuron those
could be also plastic so plastic plastic
changes could occur at different
different levels one such plastic change
could occur at synapse and synapses at
synaptic level by changing and altering
the synaptic strength and the plastic
changes at synapses could occur at
different timescales it could range from
short-term plasticity which is lasting
four minutes to long-term plasticity
which lasts for several hours two days
now probably our synapses are plastic
that idea was first posed by Romana
cahal but we can ask that what is the
measure of the plastic changes at the
level of synapses what we can use to
quantify that there is a alteration in
the synaptic strength or synaptic
transmission efficiency at a synaptic
level here is a clue in in slice culture
when you have brain slices and you are
able to record from certain neurons you
can you can stimulate the presynaptic
and you can record from Posehn
now if you stimulate the presynaptic
orde the post synaptic activity now
there are certain protocols available
which can change the synaptic strength
and these protocols are long-term
potentiation protocol which can increase
the synaptic strength for a long time
period and ltd protocol which can reduce
the synaptic strength for a long time
let's see first what happens in case of
long term potentiation protocol in order
to evoke long term potentiation
researchers give high frequency
stimulation generally 100 Hertz
frequency stimulation lasting for one
second after that high frequency
stimulation when they give same amount
of current injection they can find a
increase in amplitude of the
postsynaptic potential suggesting that
the strength of the synapses has changed
and has increased in this case other we
have seen this data is to plot the slope
over time now if the slope is more than
the baseline that means synaptic
efficacy has increased and just the
opposite is long-term depression here
you have given a current injection you
are able to record a postsynaptic
response and you give a low frequency
stimulation or 10 Hertz frequency
stimulation lasting for 10 minutes and
then you give the same amount of current
injection now you what you are able to
get is a is reduced reduced amplitude of
postsynaptic potential and other way of
showing this data is to plot the slopes
over time where you can see slopes are
after the Ltd induction the slopes are
low than the baseline suggesting that
synaptic strength could be altered and
this idea was first explored in 1962
1970 by please and Nomo and they have
used a rabbit example rabbit hippocampal
slices where they can stimulate the
porphyrin pathway coming from the
internal cortex and they can record from
the granule cells of the tented gyrus
after high frequency stimulus the same
they have seen the synaptic strength has
been increased because there is a
boosted EPS B slopes
suggesting synaptic strength has changed
and synaptic strength has increased now
the question comes whether that kind of
artificial protocol can change synaptic
strength it suggests that synapses are
not rigid they are plastic their
strength could be changed when the
question is with a similar kind of
plastic changes could happen underlined
in earning an experience dependent task
in this experiment researchers have
exposed the mouse to another dark box
where they would get a shock and this
kind of training is known as inhibitory
avoidance training it would create a
memory in the fly in the mouse brain
underlying this kind of task people have
found that in certain neuronal region
there is increase in synaptic
postsynaptic potentials that means
underlying this kind of learning tasks
their LTP like changes now people have
observed that underlines of several
learning tasks have alluvion
conditioning there is increase in
postsynaptic calcium in in in certain
region of the neuron in flight in in
drosophila people have seen an
underlying aversive conditioning when
they train the fly with the order which
is coupled with the shock and then
another another order which doesn't come
with the shock and if the fly has not
lessened properly it would avoid the
order which comes with the shock when
represented simultaneously now
underlying this kind of learning
paradigm people have found that in fly
learning center calcium levels has
increased using calcium indicator dye
they have quantified this calcium has
increased but the question is what is
the implication of calcium increase at
the postsynaptic level people found that
calcium increase is important for
synaptic strength alteration in when
calcium level is increased people can
after high frequency stimulus people
found change in synaptic strength but
when calcium is chelated that change was
gone suggesting calcium was less
also uncaging calcium at the
postsynaptic level which would
drastically increase the calcium levels
at the postsynaptic region would change
the synaptic efficacy suggesting calcium
is also important and also sufficient
for long-term potentiation or change in
synaptic strength decades of work has
summarized that there are certain
signaling pathways underlying calcium
can give rise to plastic changes and
there are certain decoder molecules
which can read the spatial temporal
dynamics of calcium and can write
plastic changes at the level of synapses
one such important player in this whole
synaptic plasticity or synaptic strength
alteration is an MD receptor NMDA
receptor is known as coincidence
detector
let's just see what coincidence detector
means here is a presynaptic action
potential coming down to the presynaptic
terminal and it is going to release
vesicle full of new transmitter and the
neurotransmitter can bind to glutamate
receptor assuming the synapse is
interpreter check and it would allow
casually it would allow cation influx
from the glutamate receptors but only
the cation could get insight from ampere
scepters not in NMDA receptors
now NMDA receptor one once sodium comes
in sodium can make the inner side of the
post synapse more depolarized there by
repelling the magnesium block and
thereby allowing calcium in calcium
influx from the NMDA receptor so the
NMDA receptor need two criteria to open
one is the binding of glutamate second
is repelling of the magnesium block and
binding of glutamate gives the NMDA
receptor idea about presynaptic activity
status while binding off while repelling
of magnesium gives the NMDA receptor
idea about the post synaptic activity
status at a molecular level presynaptic
activity status and the post synaptic
activity status are coupled and thereby
a coincidence is detected and humongous
amount of calcium flows in arresting the
resting calcium concentration inside the
or synapses hundred nano molars after go
incidents detection and thereby calcium
influx it rises tell force and goes as
high as one micromolar now if you block
the route of NMDA receptor that means if
you block the route of calcium entry by
this coincidence detector NMDA receptor
you see the synaptic strength could not
be altered the synaptic strength doesn't
increase when you block the NMDA
receptor also the animals the mouse
where the NMDA receptor was blocked by
pharmacological agent they have certain
difficulties in spatial navigation tasks
in Morris water maze now the question is
what is very important to understand is
the spatial temporal dynamics of the
calcium and the spatial temporal
dynamics of the calcium has a message
which could be decoded by certain
molecular players which can give rise to
plastic changes that the synaptic level
now these calcium dynamics could be of
different timescale and it could range
it could have different magnitude of
concentrations some calcium dynamics
could has very high max magnitude of
concentration and it could it would last
for s as long as few milliseconds
whereas whereas other calcium dynamics
could love lasts for about minutes and
it could have relatively low magnitude
and both of this kind of dynamics could
be read by different biophysical
mechanisms inside the neuron now people
have found that can k2 which is the
calcium calmodulin based protein kinase
it can read the brief and transient
increase in calcium level whereas
calcineurin which is a protein
phosphatase can read the prolonged
sustained in elevated level of calcium
and B can give rise to plastic changes
in different different ways now for
knowing more about how plastic changes
could brought about by these molecules
you can see my other videos long term
potentiation and long-term depression if
you liked this video give it a big
thumbs up please like share and
subscribe
thank you